baumann aut
la marseillaise en guise de conclusion
d'une réunion publique une habitude en
campagne présidentielle mais les paroles
prennent forcément une signification
particulière après des semaines agitées
pour le camp des républicains au bord de
l'implosion il y a quelques jours la
droite joue désormais la carte du
rassemblement derrière le candidat fille
tout le monde a conscience que si on
veut réformer notre pays est allé ans
dans le bon sens le seul qui peut à le
faire c'est françois fillon donc dwi
toute la famille est réunie
on se doit d'être assemblés dans notre
pays voilà parce que si la droite
française n'est pas présente à cette
élection présidentielle
le jeu démocratique ne pourra pas être
dépourvu pour cette réunion publique
organisée à plaisir à et xavier bertrand
et valérie pécresse président de région
notamment défendu le projet françois
fillon sécurité justice lutte contre le
terrorisme des thèmes de la droite dure
qui ont convaincu les 500 militants
présents pour l'occasion
moi j'ai fait un choix pour sauver la
france pour avoir un programme et une
personnes qui sont en adéquation est
absolument aucun c'était important c'est
un programme c'est sa personnalité
[Musique]
et puis bon
il ya présomption d'innocence et moi je
pense que c'est un honnête homme un peu
plus de quarante jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont été
également les cible de nombreuses
attaques de la part des élus
républicains
les candidats dans marché du front
national qui font désormais la course en
tête dans les sondages devant françois
fillon